hey 42 here take a seat
make yourself comfortable breathe in the
sandalwood incense
i'm about to do a psychic reading of
your personality
i'm getting the sense that you place a
lot of value on being liked
and admired at times you can be
excessively critical of yourself you
pride yourself on being an
independent thinker and you rarely
accept things
without satisfactory proof
that'll be 200 pounds please feel free
to grab a handmade potion
on your way out oh and if you could just
leave a review on tripadvisor
i'd really appreciate it even if you're
not the type of person likely to visit a
psychic
you probably saw at least something of
yourself in one of those questions
that's because they're barnum statements
declarations that appear to be unique
insights into someone's character
when really they could apply to pretty
much anyone
the barnum effect also known as the fora
effect
or the reason your anti-mage insists on
reading out your horoscope every friday
is a tried and tested technique used by
unscrupulous mystics it'll convince you
they can see into your soul
reveal the path before you and that you
don't really need all that money in your
wallet
unsurprisingly the most effective ones
tend to be quite positive
like the ones you just heard mystics who
come out with statements like
you're a bit of a wanker really aren't
you don't tend to get much repeat
as you've probably guessed by now the
technique took its name from one of the
most successful hud winkers
in history phineas taylor barnum
you might know him as the creator of the
traveling circus
the greatest show on earth the
best-selling author
of the art of money-getting and the lead
character of hollywood blockbuster
the greatest showman but barnum didn't
embrace circus life until the latter
part of his career
and although his methods of acquiring
money were indeed artful
he wasn't always the lovable hero
portrayed by hugh jackman
in the hit musical one thing's for
certain though
he made his fortune by performing some
spectacularly scandalous hoaxes
none of which were more spectacular or
scandalous
than the so-called fiji mermaid
in july 1842 an english gentleman by the
name of dr
jay griffin said to be from the british
lyceum of natural history
checked into a new york hotel the press
were expecting him
because throughout the summer they'd
been bombarded with letters from people
claiming to have met him and to have
seen some of his
truly astonishing creatures including
a particularly impressive mermaid
the press were of course desperate to
get a look at this
mythical specimen and dr griffin
being the amiable fellow that he was
obliged
now you have to remember this was a time
when our knowledge of the natural world
was extremely limited the idea that
mermaids might be real
was certainly outlandish but not quite
beyond the realms of possibility
especially considering the fact that dr
griffin's collection
included stuffed remains of several
other creatures that seemed
just as bizarre including an example of
one of mother nature's biggest practical
jokes
the build plus around this time
barnum was in the process of
transforming a rundown museum on
broadway
into barnum's american museum
hold on a second is it just me or does
that shop next door say
importers of human hair anyway
back to the museum it wasn't the kind of
dull
musty place kids get dragged around on
school trips
it featured more than 850 000
peculiar oddities including a flea
circus
and a loom powered by a dog
and naturally barnum decided that the
mermaid was a must-have
addition to his sprawling collection
unfortunately dr griffin was less than
convinced
and the two had a very public argument
over the matter
barnum appealed to dr griffin's
compassion by saying
he'd already created publicity materials
drawings which depicted the mermaid as a
seductive ocean
maiden the kind we'd recognize today
from the tales of william shakespeare
hans christian anderson and walt disney
when dr griffin refused to give in
barnum handed the drawings over to the
new york press
who promptly released them before long
the mermaid was the hot topic on
everyone's lips and with anticipation at
an
all-time high dr griffin caved in
and agreed to exhibit it for a week at
concert hall
on broadway accompanied by lectures on
his theories of natural history
and evidence demonstrating that the
mermaid was authentic
once that week was up he agreed to let
barnum feature the mermaid in his museum
unsurprisingly barnham's ticket sales
went through the roof
but when the public finally cast their
eyes on the mermaid
they were astonished they'd hoped
to see the captivating nymph-like
creature
published by the press but this mermaid
was as dead as a door nail and
utterly grotesque it had a shriveled
tail
pendulous breasts and its top half was
completely covered
in hair it was around three feet long
and its mouth was held wide open
as though it had died in pain in a
nutshell
only those with extremely niche tastes
would ever want to be seduced by it
but this was only the first of many
surprises
it came to light that the esteemed dr
griffin
had never actually existed the man
parading as dr griffin was actually
levi lyman one of barnum's
best mates and the whole affair the
letters that had appeared in the papers
the apparent spat between griffin and
barnum
was all a carefully orchestrated scam
designed to build up hype around the
mermaid
as for the mermaid itself you guessed it
it was a simple fake the torso of a
monkey
sewn to the tail of a fish it had
originally been created by japanese
fishermen
as a joke albeit a bit of a weird one
an american sea captain had for reasons
that are totally beyond me
bought this disturbing piece for a
whopping six
thousand dollars and exhibited it in a
london coffee house
until word got out that it was a fraud
after which it was transported to
america
what's more barnum knew the mermaid
wasn't legitimate
before he exhibited it as he'd already
paid a naturalist to examine it
it's the kind of hoax that stirs an
uncomfortable mixture of
begrudging respect and total repulsion
it's easy to see how barnum landed his
reputation
as a marketing extraordinaire but
putting
so much effort in to deceive his patrons
in order to line his own pockets was a
dick move by all accounts
barnum's complex relationship with the
truth
can be traced back to his childhood he
was born in 1810 in connecticut
to filo barnum an innkeeper and farmer
and his wife irene taylor young
barnum had high hopes for his future
because
from the age of six his grandfather had
promised him
he would inherit the most valuable piece
of land in town
ivy island barnum grew up
fantasizing about his prosperous future
and all the things he would do with the
land when he finally inherited it
when barnum turned 12 he was finally
allowed to see his inheritance
with his own eyes for the very first
time
with great ceremony his grandfather
along with friends and family
took a trip to ivy island but
when the group arrived barnum's
companions
burst out laughing you see this
grand inheritance the most coveted spot
of land in town
was nothing more than a dirty empty
swamp the whole thing had been a six
year long joke at barnum's expense
you might expect such a cruel revelation
would do some serious psychological
damage to a boy of 12
or at least upset him a bit but bonham
took the whole thing surprisingly well
and after a few seconds of shock he was
laughing along with everyone else
which might go some way towards
explaining the
peculiar attitude towards deception that
would later come
to define his career
although barnum wouldn't actually call
it deception
he preferred the term humbug meaning a
bit of elaborate fun
in barnum's mind as long as people felt
they were getting their money's worth
it was no harm no foul the key thing was
to give them
an unforgettable experience that would
leave them satisfied
in his own words the noblest art is that
of
making others happy but it seems that
for barnum
some people's happiness was worth more
than others and his attempts to profit
from it
weren't exactly noble as a young man
he'd flexed his industrial muscles by
selling bibles
running a grocery store and starting his
own newspaper
but he took his first dip into
showmanship
at the age of 25 after he came across a
woman called
joyce heff at the time heff was held as
a slave by the promoter r.w
lindsay who claimed she was the
childhood nurse
of george washington which in itself
would have been quite interesting
but was even more so when you considered
the fact that washington had been born
103 years previous making joyce
incredibly old unfortunately because of
those pesky anti-slavery laws
in new york and pennsylvania bonham
couldn't
buy her but being the determined young
man that he was
he found a loophole which meant he could
lease her for a year
he began promoting heff as the most
astonishing and interesting curiosity
in the world a 161 year old woman
who could tell stories about what it was
like to raise the founding father
of the united states of america heff was
not in a good way at the time
she was blind toothless had arthritis in
her hands
and was nearly completely paralyzed
but despite this barnum took her by
carriage and train to tour dozens of
towns in the northeast
where she was put on display six days a
week sometimes up to 12 hours a day
and just in case some people weren't
that impressed by a woman who defied
death bonham stirred up the hype even
further by announcing
she wasn't human at all but a curiously
constructed automaton
controlled by a ventriloquist
yeah at this point you really have to
wonder if he was just
taking the piss barnum's lease agreement
was cut short
when hef died in february 1836
after 10 months in barnum's care but the
showman had one last trick up his sleeve
there had quite understandably been
plenty of skepticism about joyce's
immense
age so barnum declared he would prove it
once and for all by hosting a public
autopsy of her body
it was not to put too fine a point on it
a pretty despicable stunt even by barnum
standards
not content with having exploited this
poor woman
in life he was now going to eek whatever
remaining profit he could out of her
cold dead body but as always pt barnum
knew his audience
the announcement of the autopsy created
a media storm
and more than 1500 tickets were sold
on the big day crowds flocked to watch
the well-known surgeon dr
david rogers dissect heff's body
his autopsy revealed that surprise
surprise
she was somewhere between 75 and 80
years old
at the time of her death the papers had
a field day
but bonham wrote it out like a pro first
suggesting he'd been tricked all along
and then that the autopsy must have
taken place on the wrong
body because the real joyce hef was
still alive and well
enjoying a tour of europe
the public didn't seem to mind either
way or if they did not enough to hinder
barnum's career
because joyce heff was in many ways
the launch pad for his fame a few years
later barnum had saved up enough
money to open his museum and boy did he
know how to make an entrance
he added a lighthouse lamp to attract
attention up and down broadway
placed giant paintings of animals
between the upper windows
and transformed the roof into a
strolling garden
which also served as a base for daily
hot air balloon rides
because why the hell not some of the
first curiosities to feature in his
museum
included wax statues of celebrities and
what was apparently a genuine cyclops
retina
but it was his so-called freak show
that really kicked things off in 1842
barnum met charlie stratton he was just
25 inches tall
bonham presented him as an 11 year old
when he was actually four or five
pretended he was from england when in
fact he was american
and gave him the name general tom thumb
barnum also taught him to sing dance and
imitate celebrities
before taking him on a grand tour of
europe
during the tour strassen met queen
victoria
mesmerizing her royal highness by having
a ceremonial sword battle
with her spaniel and if something about
that makes you feel a little
uncomfortable
you're not alone later that night queen
victoria
wrote in her diary that she pitied the
young performer
suspecting he was teased by his peers
and
wished he could be properly cared for so
even queen vic
who wasn't exactly known for her
compassion felt that
something was a bit off in 1853
barnum added one of his most popular
exhibitions to date
josephine clefulia also known as madame
clefulia
she liked to fashion her most notable
asset
a six-inch beard in the style of
napoleon iii
first president of france who was
flattered enough to give her a large
diamond in return
unfortunately for the bearded lady her
fame resulted in one of barnum's patrons
suing her
on the grounds that she was just a man
in a dress
madame clefulia was put through the
humiliation
of a medical examination to settle the
case
one way or another and was found to be a
woman
in every sense of the word even if she
was in need of a shave
the headlines drew in even more crowds
which is probably no coincidence since
it was later discovered
that barnum had once again
carefully orchestrated the publicity by
paying the plaintiff
to instigate the lawsuit
you've probably gathered by now that
barnum's mantra was
go big or go home he once attempted to
buy the american
falls section of niagara falls and fence
it off so he could charge admission
he tried to buy the ruins of pompeii but
couldn't strike a deal with the italian
government
and he even made an offer on the cottage
where william shakespeare was born
which he wanted to uproot and transfer
to new york
thankfully he was outbid by the
shakespeare association
in the summer of 1865 barnum's museum
caught fire and burnt to the ground
miraculously no human lives were lost
but the fire destroyed the fiji mermaid
and tragically boiled two beluga whales
alive in their tanks
some of the other animals escaped
although the rumors of a lion taking a
leisurely stroll through the streets of
new york were apparently false
the fire came as a big blow to barnum
but
the show must go on and so in need of a
change of direction he did what any
wealthy person with questionable morals
would do
he went into politics he was elected to
the connecticut legislature
and without a hint of irony began
campaigning for black equality and
voting rights
this was an odd direction for him to
take
for several reasons as well as
exploiting the slave joyce heff
barnum had owned slaves whilst living in
the south
and had exhibited the black man william
henry johnson
also known as zip the pinhead as a
half man half monkey who'd been found in
the wilds of africa
yeah years later barnum ran for congress
as a republican
against his democrat cousin william
barnum whilst he was running he
expressed deep remorse for his past
behavior
but it's difficult to know whether this
was just another humbug
to win over the crowds after losing the
seat to his cousin
barnum went for a bit of a rough patch
his second museum caught fire
and a few years later his wife of 40
years
died he apparently wasn't that
devastated though
because he remarried three months after
the funeral
to a 23 year old woman named nancy fish
he was 63 at the time in 1881 barnum's
luck turned when he met james bailey
at the time barnum was touring with pt
barnum's grand travelling museum
menagerie caravan and hippodrome
which he rebranded with the slightly
snappier title
the greatest show on earth meanwhile
james bailey was operating
the cooper and bayley circus with james
cooper
this rival circus was pretty good so
good in fact
it was threatening to demote barnums to
the second greatest show on earth the
star
attraction of the cooper and bailey
circus was the first elephant born in
the united states
when barnum offered to buy the elephant
bailey and cooper refused
but they eventually agreed to join with
barnum to form the giant
free-ringed barnum and bayley circus
in 1881. the next year
barnum finally got his revenge on the
brits for neglecting to sell him
shakespeare's house
by purchasing jumbo a gargantuan
six-ton african elephant from the london
zoological society
despite a series of public protests he
billed it as the largest elephant
ever seen and made it the centerpiece of
his circus
aside from being enormous jumbo had a
few tricks up his sleeve
he reportedly loved beer and cut down a
full
keg in a single sitting and he was even
used to test
the stability of the newly constructed
brooklyn bridge
along with 20 other elephants and 17
camels by the way jumbo didn't get his
name by virtue of his extreme
size as you've probably assumed
in fact the word jumbo meaning
very large entered the english language
because of this very elephant
unfortunately jumbo
circus life was short-lived and he was
killed after being struck by a freight
train
following a performance never one to
miss the opportunity to make a quick
book barnum sold various bits of jumbo
to
museums and universities around the
country
before stuffing the elephant's hide so
he could display it at his circus
eventually barnum donated the stuffed
jumbo to tufts university
where it remained until it was destroyed
in yet another fire
in his 81st year barnum fell gravely ill
and sensing the reaper was on his
doorstep he asked the evening son to
publish his obituary
in advance so he could read it two weeks
later
he died from a stroke in his bridgeport
mansion
the barnum and bailey circus continued
touring
in some form or over until as recently
as
2017. establishing itself
as a cornerstone of american culture and
to this day barnum is still known as the
greatest impresario
of all time and the glittering example
of
the american dream he was also prone to
being a bit of a douchebag with some
questionable morals but if the prince of
humbugs taught us anything
it's this whether it's an ugly mermaid
a false past or a so-called reality show
that's actually scripted
we'll all forgive a bit of hokum as long
as we've been entertained
thanks for watching check out my new
podcast
random interesting facts available on
youtube spotify
apple podcast and anywhere else you get
your podcasts
link in the description below thanks